I advise students as much as possible
look for the job that you would take if
you didn't need a job don't sleep walk
through life don't say it's all going to
be great I'll do this and I'll do that
I've told people that's like saving up
sex for your old age it is not a good
idea you really want to be doing what
you love doing and you can't necessarily
find it on your first job right but
don't give up before you find it there
was one concept that I would suggest to
people to take a daily confrontation
with is fear the problem with fear is
that it lies fear tells you hey you know
if you say that to that girl she's gonna
know she has you and she'll never really
be attracted to you if she knows how
much you attracted to her don't say that
no how we get her is when she walks by
ignore her so for me the the daily
confrontation with with fear has become
a real practice for me hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because in my first business I struggle
to believe in myself I quit on my
business partner and the thing that
saved me was watching the successful
stories of entrepreneurs they gave me
the inspiration to keep going as well as
the strategies of what to do and quite
honestly I still need their stories and
motivation today as well so today let's
live your best believe life and learn
the Five Lessons that people learn too
late in life enjoy
I went skydiving in Dubai right as
skydiving skydiving is a really
interesting confront with fear right so
so I got I gotta stand up
all right so so
all your friends what happens you go out
how you oh sorry I dropped my thing so
what happens is you go out the night
before and you you know you take a drink
with your friends and somebody says yeah
we should go skydiving tomorrow and you
go yeah we'll go skydiving well yeah
yeah yeah
and everybody goes yeah
yeah right and you go home by you by
yourself you're like um
right you're like well yeah I mean they
they was drunk too
right so so maybe maybe they're not
maybe maybe I mean we don't have to go
we don't have to do it so then at night
you're laying in your bed and you just
keep
and you're terrified you keep imagining
over and over again jumping out of an
airplane and you can't figure out why
you would do that right and you lay in
there and you have the worst night's
sleep of your life but you still have
the hope that your friends were drunk
right so you wake up the next day and
you go you know down and you said where
you were gonna meet and everybody's
there you're like oh
um all right all right cool cool cool
cool cool cool right so you get in the
van and you don't know that your friends
had the same night that you had because
they're pretending like they didn't
they're like yeah man my uncle's a Navy
SEAL and you know it's gonna be great
I've been looking forward to this and
you're like oh my God oh my God and your
stomach is terrible you can't eat and
everything but you don't want to be the
only Punk who doesn't jump out of this
airplane so you get there and then you
have the safety brief and you're
standing there and the guys will tell
you well if the shoot doesn't open
what's going to happen is you doing
what can happen
that the shoe the shoe wouldn't open
right so you do a thing and what you do
is your first jump you're attached to a
guy who he's going you know he's going
to walk you out so you go and you get
there and there's an airplane and
nobody's stopping everybody's still
going so you get onto the airplane and
you're sitting there and and you know
it's extra because you're sitting on
some dude's lap some stranger
you're sitting on his lap and it's like
you know you got trying to make small
talk yeah man
so you do you be jumping with people all
the time huh
right you know so and then you just want
to make sure yo you got you got kids
right you got people you need to see
make sure he's serious right so you get
in there so everything's normal so you
fly and you go up you go up you go up
you go up to 14 000 feet and you notice
there's a a light it's red and it's
yellow and green right so right now the
light's red so then you start thinking
at some point the light's going to go
green but you don't know what's going to
happen right and you wait and it goes
yellow and the light goes green and
somebody opens the door and in that
moment you realize you've never been in
a freaking airplane with the door open
right Terror oh sorry I'm spitting oh
sorry no terror terror terror terror
right so you go and then you know if
you're if you were smart you sat in the
back so you don't go first right and
then people start going out of the
airplane and you go and the guy walks
you up to the end of the thing and
you're standing and your toes are on the
edge and you're looking out down to
death
and they say on three and they say one
two and he pushes you on two because
people grab on three right
right and you go
and you fall out of the airplane and in
one second you realize that it's the
most Blissful experience of your life
you're flying right it doesn't feel like
falling right it's like the you actually
are kind of held a little bit by the
wind and then you start and you you
start falling you're falling and you
there's zero fear you realize at the
point of Maximum danger is the point of
minimum fear it's Bliss it's Bliss and
you're flying
right and you're doing it and then 20
seconds 25 seconds 40 seconds and you
have enough time to just kind of be like
ah that's that building that's not
like that one
oh you can see the ocean
right you start doing all of that and
the the lesson for me was why were you
scared in your bed the night before
why did you what do you need that fear
for just don't go why are you scared in
your bed 16 hours before you jump why
are you scared in the car why could you
not enjoy breakfast what what what did
you need to fear is fear of what you're
nowhere and even near the airplane
everything up to the stepping out
there's actually no reason to be scared
it only just ruins your day you don't
have to jump and then in that moment all
of a sudden where you should be
terrified is the most Blissful
experience of your life and God placed
the best things in life on the other
side of Terror on the other side of your
maximum fear are all of the best things
in life also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the lessons
learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
lesson number three stop complaining
what if I told you this was the last
Monday morning of your life what if I
told you you die this week would you
complain about your crap job or that
test you don't want to take I doubt it
you would go much higher level thinking
well that's really what it takes it
takes understanding that if you're not
pumped right now if you're begrudging
what you're about to do if you're if
you're not looking forward to it look I
respect practicality you got to go
through school because your parents want
to you got to pay your rent you got
student loans I get it but please
recognize the world we're living in
we're living in a world where there's so
much more opportunity this internet
thing created way more opportunity for
all of us way more I mean look you might
not even be alive like your mom and Dad
could have had sex like three minutes
later and you wouldn't even exist and
you're complaining you could have ended
up being a bus a tree I just don't get
the mentality of being head down sad on
a Monday morning I'm gonna make Monday
morning my I'm Gonna Make You
Saturday Monday morning that's what I
want to do every morning and that's what
I want from you please take a step back
and think about how awesome it actually
is and then recognize that you can
attack the world in a totally different
way because you were lucky enough to be
born during this era lesson number four
know your destination imagine we're
standing
in a big empty room right and we're
standing in one corner and I give you a
simple instruction
I want you to go to that corner in a
straight line
right off you go no big deal right
without telling you I slip a chair in
front of you what do you do
you go around the chair
now you just disobeyed what I told you
to do I told you to go to that corner
straight line but this is the amazing
things about human beings which is when
we're given a clear destination
we use our own creativity and our own
sense of innovation and our own
problem-solving abilities to overcome
obstacles to get to the destination in
other words the destination is more
important than the route
right we're flexible about the root
we're obsessed with the destination
reset we're standing in the corner
together and I give you a simple
instruction go somewhere in this room in
a straight line
and you say to me where do you want me
to go I'm like I don't know you're smart
figure it out go in a straight line and
so you pick a point and you start
walking and without telling you I put a
chair in front of you what do you do you
come to a grinding Halt and I say what'd
you stop for you go will you put a chair
in front of me
or you'll make a sudden turn on going
another Direction
right and this is the problem it's the
same obstacle the difference is when you
have a clear clear destination the
obstacles become easy to overcome when
you don't have a clear destination you
keep coming to a grinding Halt and what
we do in our companies is we're counting
the steps we're taking along the Route
but we're never looking at the
destination right so company says made a
million dollars this year we were only
planning on making 800 000 like we took
10 steps we're only planning on taking
eight
where are you going no clue right
we count the steps and so the point is
is that people want to feel that the
effort that they're exerting actually
are moving somewhere and so successful
measurements successful recognition is
not just for the steps you take it's not
just for the effort it's that the effort
you exerted moved us closer to where
we're trying to get to and that get to
should be some crazy ideal my ideal is
to live in a world in which the vast
majority of people wake up every single
morning you know inspired to go to work
and fulfilled by the work that they do
and the the couple of measurements that
I use are if the book is selling and I
by the way people ask me how many have
you sold I have no clue I've never asked
the publisher because I don't care I
really don't care how many I've sold
what I care about is the Amazon rankings
and that those are going steady or up
and not plummeting because that means
other people right because I don't have
a publicist I don't have a marketing
strategy on purpose I didn't hire one of
those companies to sell the book for me
and the reason is is because I'm not
interested in Book Sales I'm interested
in spreading of an idea and so I just
use that as a metric to help me
understand am I sort of Marching In the
because the more I pre each is it
resonating you know and so you have a
couple of these imperfect measurements
that help you understand are you going
along the way so it's not just great
effort look what you achieved because
that's what we're doing now right our
goal is to increase Top Line revenues by
50 million dollars
for what reason
right which is we have to know the
destination and then we say amazing you
took us that much closer and if we go to
the right it's because we were
overcoming an obstacle if we hadn't gone
to the right we would have been stuck
forever thank you you know it's not
always straight lines it's not always
straight lines
but it's it's in One Direction she's
pulling the cane out
I'm not sure about that in the future I
can I would dictate I would be stupid
that's why I should retire early when
I'm young that is why I have a lot of
things that the dream I want to do I
want to philosophy I want to be a
teacher I want to go back to school I
want to do the environment and the world
is so wonderful why you should be the
CEO of Alibaba all the time I'm coming
to this world
not to work I want to come to this world
to enjoy my life I don't want to die in
my office I want to die on the beaches
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to learn
the 10 skills that will make you rich
check your video right there next to me
I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there one of
the things you would want to be sure to
do uh is whether you like it or not get
very comfortable it may take a while
with public speaking for example I mean
that